the number one fan of this movie so far
has been Beyonce and Blue Ivy
Beyonce made it a mother-daughter date
night with Blue Ivy last week at the
world premiere of Beauty and the Beast
in Hollywood on Monday at the New York
City premiere the cast of the new Disney
flick proved they're just like us total
Beyonce super fans did you get a chance
to meet them at the screening the other
night but I was so touched to see if you
wanna say and Blue Ivy you dressed up
together to come to the movie didn't see
Queen B I'm so sad
you know I will come dressed up as the
food to your home and say hi to your
children if I can just shake I know I
know I I heard that she loved it I
missed her I did get to see her I mean
it's amazing when you see Beyonce
I began came to Japan girl I saw her and
literally I went green I'm happy to
receive her whenever she would like to
pay personal tribute no I didn't get to
meet her Sally but I did sit directly
behind Celine Dion at the Hollywood
premiere and I spent the entire movie
sort of watching the movie through the
back of Celine Dion's head just going
that's Celine Dion watching beating the
bees this is the strangest thing
you
you